our truth and it makes for difficult
listening have you ever seen anything
like this before 30 years as a medical
practitioner and 10 years as a
consultant no I have never seen anything
like this ever I'm talking to an
emergency consultant desperately trying
to save lives in a South London hospital
he fears he's losing the battle against
covert 19 are you worried I am I'm very
worried it's actually quite horrifying
to think that we could be completely
swamped we are professionals and we know
what we're doing and we know how to
handle stress but it's it's a stress
shock to the system where you know you
are going to be in a situation where
there are patients you could have saved
in normal circumstances but the
resources are not there the staff are
not there all of the things that you'd
normally require will not be there to
save these people we're protecting our
doctors identity and he's protecting our
safety he didn't want to meet after
being exposed to patients with kovat 19
some people have described kovat as
being like the flu
it really isn't not not the way we are
seeing it the unwell people are
seriously unwell
we are getting people coming in with
full-blown really nasty pneumonia the
capital is the UK's coronavirus hotspots
there are more deaths and positive cases
here than anywhere else currently is
your intensive care unit full are you at
capacity or will you be there very soon
actually it has remained above capacity
we've we've got overflow any
availability we are having is because of
people dying the government's handling
of the crisis has been fiercely
criticised their lack of testing their
lack of protective equipment and the
lack of clear direction on social
distancing most of my colleagues that I
know went we're not
setting out to be heroes but yes we are
aware of the potential risks to
ourselves and it almost feels like you
are slightly being used as as cannon
fodder and slightly expendable if we
fall sick we are not available to treat
anybody our doctor has seen our report
on the shocking situation in northern
Italy it is catastrophic there but he
has a grim warning for us here but I
actually think it could be worse than
that because I'm aware of the Italian
system and I think in quite a few ways
there are in advance of us in terms of
resources and the intensive care beds
that they had available prior to this
occurring so I think we may actually end
up in a worse state than they presently
are unless we take sufficient measures
right now maybe talking days are
probably more weeks but possibly days
our doctor has agreed to speak to Sky
News because he wants us to know what is
happening right now
inside his hospital the situation is at
crisis point and we have yet to reach
the peak Ashish Joshi sky news